représentant la France LAN
is
intense
et super pleine
d'émotions c'est ce que je lui ai dit
c'est un AGR après un AGR on essaie de
faire petit à petit et on essaie de se
remettre dans le concours de faire les
quatre avec sérénité et tranquillité bah
il me connaît un peu beaucoup maintenant
donc oui c'est sûr
que c'est c'est c'est bien d'avoir son
entraîneur avec soi pour pour des
compèes comme
ça
il a des filles vachement plus grandes
que toi oui beaucoup plus grandes qui
ont parfois plus 15 ans de
plus c'est filles qu'il faut aller
détrôner mais pour l'instant euh là faut
que j'engrange beaucoup de
compétitions pour pouvoir vraiment être
sereine et comme elle
quoi la fiche c'est nous qui l'avons fa
vous venu tout l' oui elle est en forme
il reste la ouais croise on a pe on
petite ché quand même que la réunion
soit représentée là oui ouais la réun
ben on va chercher les petits 10e pour
pour augmenter encore le total de points
parce que c'est ça qu'il faut à chaque
fois chaque jour
amélior merci de m'encourager et d'être
là toujours à croire en
moi parce que
ça ça aide avant tout à à performer tu
sou reenne quoi cette semaine expérience
expérience expérience on fait beaucoup
de sacrifices parce que nos parents sont
plus loin que certains et la Réunion
faut la faire un peu sortir de de son
océan la réunion je vous embrasse vous
aime fort et à
bientôt